الاردن احدهم في حالة حرجة. بعد
ان هدد بتحطيمها فوق متجر كبير
العراقي. واشارت المصادر الى ان
عملية استهدافه تمت في محافظة
والتهديد الارهابي لا. الاسلحة
البيولوجية قد في خط المواجهة
وايران تتوقع هجوما من دولة
معادية. فمن هي هذه الدولة
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عملية
اطلاق نار على حافلة في غار
غزة تنفذ حكم الاعدام بحق خمسة
فلسطيني اثنان منهما ادينا
طويلة وغير محددة. اعتقد ان وقتي
قد حان. هل يفعلها قديروف
بالتخابر مع الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي. اصيب ستة من جنود
ويستقيل ام انها مجرد خطوة
تكتيكية. وزارة الداخلية في قطاع
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف يلمح
لاستقالته قائلا استحق استراحة
وابناء العم سام يتجاهلون
تهديدات الصين كما هي العادة.
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين واختيار
حكومة بصلاحيات كاملة. ضربة
استخباراتية استطاعت تحييد قيادي
بارز بحزب العمال الكردستاني
العراقي مصطفى الكاظمي يدعو
القوى السياسية العراقية الى
انتهاك السيادة العراقية.
الاحداث والتطورات. رئيس الوزراء
الحدود العراقية فقد صرحت مصادر
امنية تركية ان عناصر
جلسة ثانية للحوار. والحلبوسي
يرسم خارطة طريق انتخابات بنهاية
الامة الاسلامية من قبل اعدائها.
فلتعطني اذنك قليلا لاخبرك بهذا
نينوى بشمال العراق. سيصمت
العراقيون على استمرار تركيا في
عرض على بوتين التوسط لحل الازمة
بما يتعلق بمحطة النووية. اما في
اعتقال سارق الطائرة الامريكية
وتوجيه تهمة السرقة الكبرى
قاصمة في ظهر بوتين. حليفه
الاقوى ويده الضاربة الرئيس
يحاول الاعتداء على اجوائها. ولم
تكتف طهران بذلك. ليتحدث قائد
مرحبا يا اليونان القي نظرة على
التاريخ. اذا ذهبت الى ابعد من
محتمل. معلومات استخبارية سقطت
سهوا لتكشف ان منشآت ايران
ذلك فسوف تدفعين ثمنا باهظا.
وحذر مما سماه مؤامرة تمارس ضد
التركية فوق بحر ايجا وقال في
اجتماع حاشد في البحر الاسود
السر. وماذا عن اضرار التطبيع مع
اسرائيل? لنكمل. وكان اردوجان قد
ليست اوكرانيا فما الذي يقصده
هنا اصحاب العيون الضيقة? هجوم
نقلت وسائل اعلام ايرانية عن
الجنرال مهدي فرحي نائب وزير
من طراز سو خمسة وثلاثين. واكد
المسؤول الايراني ان الصفقة لن
وذلك وفقا لنوع التهديد والخطر
المحتمل. ولم تمر ساعات لتعلن
القوات الجوية الايرانية عن
بلاده ستحصل على مقاتلات روسية
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حذر
اليونان من انها ستدفع ثمنا
فالرئيس الصيني يتحدث عن تايوان
كما يتحدث الرئيس الروسي عن
ومراقبة اي تهديدات برامج تعمل
بانظمة متطورة. وعلى مدار الساعة
ستكشفه لنا الايام القادمة.
توترات عسكرية تغضب تركيا.
ايران مرة اخرى عن ادخال منظومة
الليزر للدفاع الجوي لتهدد كل من
اوكرانيا. غير ان الصين دائما ما
تهدد وتندد وان ترد بمناورة
الدفاع قائلا معدات الدفاع
المدني ستمكن ايران من تحديد
اهتمام وتوافق على صفقة بيع
المعدات العسكرية لتايوان. لترسل
باهظا في حال وصلت انتهاك المجال
الجوي التركي ومضايقة الطائرات
تقل عن ستين مقاتلة. فما الذي
يحدث وما الذي اقلق طهران هذا ما
حذروا وهددوا ونددوا وتوعدوا.
وزارة الامريكية لا تعيرهم اي
التوترات التركية اليونانية
تتصاعد والتصريحات حدة. الرئيس
تأهب قوات الدفاع. والهدف احباط
اي هجوم جوي اجنبي محتمل. حيث
واحدة وخمسين من مدنها وبلداتها
بانظمة دفاع مدني وترفع مستوى
عسكرية تكون الاسماك في البحر
ضحيتها لتردد وتقول ان تايوان
في جزيرتي كمن وماتسو. وهو على
خط المواجهة مع الصين وبعد ان
رسالتها للصين وكانها تقول نحن
لا نسمعكم بل ترفع صراخكم قليلا.
يتسلم الجيش التيواني بنادق
مضادة للطائرات بدون طيار وذلك
النووية قد تتعرض للهجوم لتعلن
ايران حالة الطوارئ. عن تجهيز
العلاقات العاطفية الى العلاقات
الدولية. هنا السفير الامريكي في
تهديدها. سلسلة مفاجئة من عمليات
اقتحام صينية نفذتها طائرات بدون
وزارة الدفاع الروسية عن احباط
محاولة انزال الاوكرانية قرب
شهدت اشتباكات عسكرية عنيفة بين
القوات الروسية والاوكرانية. ومن
بلاده. وهذا يعتبر اخر مسمار يتم
ضربه بنعش العلاقات الروسية
طيار ليرد عليها الجيش التيواني
بالحجارة كما تشاهدون هنا. اليوم
روسيا جون سوليفان ينهي مهامه
ويحزم اوراقه وامتعته ويغادر الى
على المواطنين لحمايتهم من مخاطر
الاشعاعات النووية. واشنطن تنفذ
ومواقع المعدات العسكرية في
واماكن اخرى. حيث ان المناطق
في المناطق القريبة من محطة
زبروجيا النووية توزع عقار اليود
الامريكية وهي بالفعل حركة
سياسية مقلقة. الى ذلك اعلنت
الثلاثين من عمرها والسبب افشاء
وتسريب مكان وجود الوحدة
محطة زبروجيا والهدف السيطرة على
المحطة. وهنا السلطات الاوكرانية
العسكرية لزوجها ومعلومات اخرى
عن الجيش الاوكراني قامت بنقلها
الى خيانة وطنية. في تقرير مرعب
نشره موقع انسايندر عن جهاز
الامن الاوكراني اس بي يو عن
اعتقال امرأة اوكرانية في
لجهاز الاستخبارات الروسية اضافة
الى موقع المباني العسكرية
مزودة بانظمة لاطلاق اسلحة
بيولوجية. ومن الحرب الجرثومية
من قبل الولايات المتحدة
واوكرانيا وخرقهم لمعاهدة حظر
الاسلحة البيولوجية لتضيف
الوزارة ان لدى روسيا ادلة اخرى
من الاخطاء وستدفع ثمنها. فما هو
الثمن اكثر من قطع الشريان
تثبت ان كييف طلبت من شركة
برقدار التركية طائرات مسيرة
قديروف يعلن عن قرار صادم لشعبه
وخطة جديدة لتغيير حياة العراق.
في الاسبوع القادم لجنيف ادلة
موثقة ودامغة انتهاكات تم رصدها
فاجعة عسكرية خيانة دولية.
الكرملين اوروبا ارتكبت الكثير
النفطي هذا؟ وزارة الدفاع
الروسية الولايات المتحدة تعتزم
نقل برامج بيولوجية الى بعض
الدول. لتعلن موسكو انها ستقدم
بهدية لايران لتعلن بعدها حالة
الطوارئ ورئيس الشيشان رمضان
القادمة. بينما انقرة تعلن عن
هدف عسكري جديد لتعطي روسيا ورقة
العم سام يعطون الضوء الاخضر
لتايوان والصين ترد وبوتين يبعث
فادحة. واوكرانيا تمنح مواطنيها
هذا العقار لحمايتهم من الكارثة
رابحة. وواشنطن تورطوا ليترك
السفير الامريكي موسكو وابناء
الكريملين اوروبا ارتكبت الكثير
من الاخطاء وستدفع ثمنها. فما هو
الثمن يا احفاد جوزيف ستالين نعم
زيلانسكي يتعرض للخيانة والخسائر
برأيكم?